[Applause]
Nick Cannon is eating bugs and Nicole
Scherzinger got bangs hey guys welcome
back to another week of unmasking the
masked singer I'm Charlie okie good I'm
Deidre Bay her what the heck is this
show turning into fear factor I mean or
labia a makeover show the coal rockin
with bangs so fierce of course welcome
back to unmasking the masked singer
we're still at home in quarantine but we
are ready to dive right in and talk
about the Battle of the sixes that is
right tonight sadly to the astronaut did
not land on the moon but instead in the
eliminated contestant spot take a look
it's been an unbelievable experience
this time in my life is a great chance
for me to sort of hit a reset button and
to try a bunch of things that I was
scared of and this show is full of those
Oh Charlie are you are you a country fan
country music not a huge country person
I don't think you are either but we're
not guessing him since day one yes I
will you know lightly pat ourselves on
the back for that I'm not a huge country
fan but I'll tell you what I am a huge
Hunter Hayes fan and I really loved the
the broad diversity that he showed off
in this competition doing songs of so
many different genres and I applaud him
he said that he kind of reached a point
in his career where he needs to push
reset take the second figure out what he
wants to do moving forward and where
better to sort of regroup than the mass
did you like watching I loved watching
him and I think it was great tonight he
said after the helmet came off his
astronaut helmet back he got to do a lot
of things on this show he wouldn't
normally do he's not someone who
normally dances doing country music on
top of that he got to vocally challenged
himself a bit and do some pop songs like
One Direction tonight he normally
wouldn't perform right oh my god the pop
deliciousness was so good and before we
move on I just want to call out they did
these really fun literally delicious
clues tonight called the mask
Munchie clue so everybody brought out a
food item and the astronaut brought out
this cake of different colors I wasn't
familiar with it I've never been to
Mardi Gras in my life or I've never even
been to Louisiana but hunter is from
Louisiana he's a huge fan of this king
cake and I'm he actually aided on The
Ellen Show in 2014 have you ever had
King cake I have not but I think this
calls for a trip to Louisiana oh oh wow
I was gonna say calls for us eating king
cake on camera but I'll go to Louisiana
last season king cake this one exactly
jumping right into it we have five more
performers to talk about first off the
kitty who showed us tonight that under
pressure she emerges at the diamonds
[Music]
well I think after tonight we're
changing the song - diamonds are a
Kitty's best friend yes they are she's
been so regal and so dazzled throughout
this whole competition and of course we
still think the kitty is Jackie Evancho
the opera singer the young talent would
be huge huge huge voice the clue package
tonight was full of new and fun things
to decode the first thing that grabbed
my attention was actually a clue you've
seen before it was that little Red
Riding Hood costume now jackie has
actually played Little Red Riding Hood
before she was cast in the title role in
her school's musical version so it's a
role she's familiar with I know we threw
out Lucy Hale a few weeks back but no
for sure Jackie Ivanka what did you
think we also saw a silver Apple in a
mirror Jackie actually does have an
album called songs from the silver
screen kind of showing her love for
classic movies and songs that come from
those films not necessarily a screen we
saw the Apple in but we saw a lot of
silver in that moment so I'm sticking
with songs from a silver apple a very
sort of a screen she's looking at an
image projected in there so don't come
for us in the comments if you think that
abstraction it's there also we saw the
clapping monkey at music box which if
you're a huge Broadway fan like me you
know that is a nod to a prop and one of
the huge storyline points in Phantom of
the Opera and Phantom of the Opera is
what Jackie says actually inspired her
to start singing Wow well your Broadway
knowledge is just coming in collect left
and right this season
and speaking of opera we had Gordon
Ramsay celebrity chef extraordinaire up
there tonight and we saw them take out
their Munchie clues and he actually
decoded what the cake for the kitty was
he says it's classically referred to as
an opera cake with Jackie Evancho it is
it is and moving on to our next
performer we have the Rhino who
certainly charged at us with another
great performance check it out
baby I
it's our guy
Barry Zito ziti tortellini all of the
above
yes overall a great performer I can say
that
ya know he flexes those vocals every
single week former MLB player turned
really brilliant musician who delivers
every single week what did you take away
from the glue package well one of the
first things we saw in the glue package
was the Rhino in a Zen space in the
mountains doing some yoga with a quick
search you can actually find out that
various ido is a huge practicer and
believer in stings and through yoga and
meditation it's actually been reported
and seen by plenty of people in the
stands that Barry Zito while playing in
the MLB it used to do yoga all the time
in the half which is so funny and goes
to show that you have to get Zen before
those big games high stakes baseball
calls for lots of practice of meditation
yes it does
my big takeaway from from the Rhinos
clue package was the colorful guitar
picks so if you know Barry Zito you know
he's an amazing guitar player he
actually picked up the guitar in 1999 as
a way to kind of pass time on these long
road trips in between games and quickly
we will mention be food flew he saw
there it could possibly be a clue
referencing Barry spaghetti and
meatballs deidre am I trying for this
one too hard absolutely not isn't he
Italian he is and he was inducted into
the National Italian Sports Hall of Fame
National Italian American Sports Hall of
Fame in 2017 well deserved and I hope
that this Italian food is a nod to our
boy Barry Zito though thank you three
totally well the Frog gave us both hip
and hop tonight
take a look
[Applause]
hands-down my favorite performance of
the evening we think this is Bow Wow the
the rapper that we have known and loved
for decades what did you think of this
performance listen I think the frog is
doing whatever it takes to make it far
in this competition
yeah he's overcompensating because he's
not someone who's known as a vocalist I
thought this was a brilliant song choice
because the imagine dragons original
version it's basically rapping but it's
got those big bass sounds and it's more
rock and it gave us a chance to see him
doing something different but it was
still very much in his wheelhouse
I digress I'm obsessed with the frog
let's get into his clue package we saw a
basketball so we know he was obviously
in the movie like Mike and then Michael
Jordan famously number 23 but the jersey
was flipped backwards so it's really
like a 32 and at the time when this was
filmed Bow Wow would have been 32 years
old he recently turned to a 33 in March
that makes a lot of sense to me
sure thing so right on the other like
moment of numerology was the number 13
on a white notepad the number 13 is
significant because that's how old he
was when he released his first album
beware a dog in the year 2000 I was not
releasing albums when I was 13 like I
was doing very odd impressive things
when I was 13 also another thing we saw
we saw a Twinkie in the clue package he
actually played a character named
Twinkie in the 2006 movie The Fast and
Furious Tokyo Drift which a lot of you
actually pointed out last week we saw a
Japanese flag I connected it to the band
Bow Wow
which is big in Asia apparently but it
also has to do with Tokyo Drift and just
pointing out a quick nod to the mast
Munchie clue we saw a catfish on a plate
I obviously thought does this have to do
with where he's from is it a signature
dish it actually has to do with the MTV
dating gone wrong show situation catfish
because bow-wow was the subject of an
episode when a woman thought she was
dating Bow Wow who was not Wow
then he later addressed it my god that
poor woman
could you imagine thinking you're dating
bow out no and I hope she's watching the
masked singer and puts this all together
and it comes full circle
exactly moving on to my favorite
contestant the night angel it gave us a
performance tonight as smooth as velvet
take a look
[Music]
more ridiculously incredible vocals from
the night angel you guys come on kandi
Burruss it takes real talent and real
chops to sing a song like black velvet
and she did it so much justice tonight
night angels your favorite are you are
you okay like are you in one of these
I'm just overwhelmed every week it's a
great song choice it's a bad performance
and it's a great clue package tonight
because we found out some new things
about kandi who we are assuming is under
that mask so we saw a lot of phones they
were hanging from the ceilings they
showed us dialing numbers on the screen
it was almost like an infomercial oh
good
[ __ ] well the rotary phone it doesn't
actually have to do with the phone
itself but it has to do with the phone
being off the hook which was the album
title of her girl group escapes second
album then I mean speaking of escape and
in that era of music in the infomercial
in the clue package it said the angel
hotline you must be 2000 years old or
older to call of course 2000 the
explosion of pop and R&B and that whole
wave of music which kandi was such a
huge part of we also saw that it costs
two dollars and eighty five cents a
minute if you'd like to call the hotline
of course I to 85 is the interstate
highway in Atlanta Georgia where kandi
lives so that's not compelling evidence
also tried calling kandi does not pick
up just will have to take it up with her
once she's unveils that's correct and
what did you think about the masked
Munchie clue you actually pointed out a
great a great reason okay so we saw bugs
and my first reaction is Oh disgusting
you can't not this is Deidre Behar is
not going on fear factor anytime soon
ladies and gentlemen Nick Cannon was
very brave and I was like you know
eating bugs does the does candy like
bugs you guys it's not that difficult
she co-wrote the song Bugaboo by
Destiny's Child back in that delicious
mm era of music
I don't think you've sent deliciousness
in fog I just can't get over it yeah
they don't final performer of the night
such certainly be celebrating for
securing a spot in the top five take a
look deidre I know you love the turtle I
love this hurdle the fans love the
turtle we are sticking with Jesse
McCartney as our guest what did you
think of the song choice another week
another phenomenal performance by the
turtle I mean he and the Frog and the
night angel in my opinion are the ones
to beat he shows that he can do so many
different styles of music but more
importantly he's always performing
impeccably commanding the stage and
capturing everyone's attention let's get
to the clue package what did you think I
mean it was pretty literal right from
the start we saw them almost on like a
giant checkers chess board don't dig too
deep because Jesse McCartney who we are
sticking with as our guest literally has
a song called check me so there you go
and at the end of that lovely chess
match we saw the turtle snatched the
masked singer trophy and in place
he put a stuffed Ram we know that Jesse
McCartney has actually performed at
Angelo State stadiums Ram Jam so I don't
know is that a stretch too much I
thought maybe he had a pet Ram but
that's probably a lot less likely a
little less likely I'm gonna go in the
concert performance there what'd you
find out from the masked punchy of the
turtle so this was the most bizarre in
my opinion we saw a colorful medley of
chips with an apple salsa which I agree
with Gordon Ramsay that's just
disgusting
Ramsay was not having it with that I was
all appalled by it so a couple of things
the apple salsa well we know Jesse's
from New York the Big Apple and then he
specifically noted that it was a
colorful medley of chips well Jesse's
album from 2014 is actually called in
Technicolor lots of bright imagery for
all of that stuff so I don't know if
Emily gets pointing to Jesse guys apple
salsa maybe no but Jesse it's a yes
all right guys that does it for us
another episode of unmasking the masked
singer but the good news does not end
here Charlie and I are so excited we're
gonna be speaking with the astronaut aka
Hunter Hayes we're gonna get to the
bottom of all things behind the scenes
secrets about the costume about his
performance and and what's next I want
to know what he's gonna do with this new
reset in his career so I'm very excited
about that checking to online.com and
next week we'll be back to talk all
about the Fab five our favorite five
making it to the top five for next week
I feel like we have been covering the
show for what feels like eternity and we
are getting down to the end we have the
Frog the Rhino the night angel the kitty
and the turtle all battling it out for
that golden masked trophy and of course
send us your guesses let us know who you
think is going to take home that trophy
and we will be here to talk about it
next week bye guys
[Music]